la farine vous connaissez bien cet
aliment on utilise beaucoup en
pâtisserie et plus généralement en
cuisine on peut aussi s'en servir en
photographie arnaud que nous montrer
comment suivez moi bonjour arnaud
bonjour qu'émile alors on est là du coup
dans le le studio la scène de crime à
sion si on peut dire alors comment ce
que vous est venue l'idée de commencer
la faute aux farines en fait je faisais
des photos chez moi des gouttes d'eau
pour faire un petit peu des photos
artistiques et puis un jour je me suis
dit tiens je vais faire des photos et
avec la farine
donc voilà je me suis mis delà de la
farine sur les cheveux j'ai fait un
espèce de mouvement de profil et du coup
voilà ça a donné la première photo
farine
voilà c'était moi j'ai deux cobayes donc
c'est vraiment on est vraiment
commencement là du coup si les premiers
portraits vous propose également au
public exactement quand on va tester ça
aujourd'hui alors est-ce que déjà la
bonne tenue pour alors moi je désire
avoir le moins de tissu possible au
niveau du haut parce qu'en fait la photo
de son à s'arrêter au niveau de l'épaule
jamais avoir les polémiques moi très
bientôt
bon bah on va être parti alors du coup
je vais enlever la veste et puis on est
parti ça marche
le but du jeu maintenant c'est de
s'asseoir d'accord une fois qu'on est
assis donc deux profils vous allez
mettre la tête dans un petit peu en
avant je vais mettre de la farine sur
les cheveux d'accord et ensuite le
mouvement s'il est très très simple si
juste un mouvement de la tête qui va te
bas vers le haut
un mouvement assez sec et rapide parce
que si c'est roland fait là paris nous a
pas vraiment de trop le ballon qu'il
faut c'est qu'ils rapide aller 1 2 3 4
voilà ça c'est parfait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la séance est terminée donc on a
fait deux styles de portrait différent
de profil donc je lançais la tête comme
ça et puis de façon je faisais un grand
nom très très convaincu disons est-ce
que ça a indiqué pour tout type de
personnes même si on n'a jamais fait de
photographier c'est vraiment accessible
à tout le monde c'est accessible à tout
le monde en fait la personne de
portraits accepte beaucoup plus
facilement que de s'y opposer parlant
dans un jardin etc
et puis ça reste des photos artistiques
et je pense que les gens quand ils te
vois ne serait ce qu'avec la farine dans
les cheveux etc
je trouve que voilà leur regard ces
merveilles et il adore la photo comme ça
en tout cas c'est quoi la prochaine
étape là du coup donc là on a fait les
photos brut que vous allez vers travail
et aussi après ça va tout à fait je la
travaille seulement l'ordinateur et une
fois qu'ils aient travaillé ce pont là
je les envoie aux personnes qui sont
intéressées
danse vous je vous envoie et puis à ce
moment-là vous voudrez celle que vous
voulez garder pour de bon voilà bon bah
voilà moi j'ai testé en tout cas avec
arnaud donc n'hésitez pas à le contacter
arnaud choc sinon qu'il est à fontenay
le fleury est puis sera ravi de vous
tirer le portrait de la farine c'est ma
petite vengeance personnelle triple à
[Musique]